[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le dernier
cyan par les spores de cette édition
2018 2019 les missions qu'il nous faut
absolument pas manquer si vous êtes un
amoureux du sport local et surtout des
jeux olympiques car l'émission sera
intégralement consacré aux jo
pour cette dernière nous nous sommes mis
en tenue estivale comme vous pouvez le
voir mais rassurez-vous les quatre
chroniqueurs présents sur ce plateau ne
sont pas encore en vacances présentation
en musique on commence à ma droite sur
la plage on le surnomme le david
hasselhoff de vélizy des toujours
parfaitement affûté les toujours prêts à
aider en cas de pépin le sauveur le
capitaine yann dujarrier piste à octobre
2006 68 est encore avec nous on passe de
l'autre côté c'est notre sirène
aujourd'hui elle est aussi sublime qu'un
coucher de soleil sur la mer egée à nous
vient tout droit de versailles notre
ambassadrice de charme la très sportive
hélène de la grange est avec nous on
passe de l'autre côté son bronzage et le
travail quant à lui sur le terrain les
terrains de golf ou sur les terrains de
rugby des dieux où il n'hésite pas à
faire du topless son passe temps favori
le lion le gladiateur pierre chevalier
du rugby-club de versailles est avec
nous on termine
de l'autre côté les de retour dans cette
émission après plus de deux heures
d'absence pourquoi il est revenu on lui
a tout simplement dit qu'on allait
parler des jeux olympiques 2024 et qu'il
aurait un tee shirt qui pourrait se
mettre en tee shirt sur cette émission
l'anssi pl l'encyclopédie basile rigoli
est avec nous bonjour à tous les quatre
yann comment vous allez moyens mois il a
recommencé un super coup de froid avec
les changements climatiques limburg
chaleur des derniers jours ça se voit
par ci un petit peu ça semble un petit
peu fier toujours bien c'est sympa cette
petite ambiance détendue on a laissé
faire cette émission un jour en tongs
par exemple pour vous et non ça je
n'aurais pas parié dessus un kopeck au
début mais c'est plus c'est sympa
pouvoir le faire dans des bonnes
conditions à mikel estivale
hélène vous aussi vous êtes en tenue
estivale oui vraiment comme quand je
suis en vacances donc c'est très bien on
est un peu comme à la maison ici deux
heures c'est très bien pour une petite
et chaleureux
basile rigoler vous êtes de retour dans
cette émission je disais après deux ans
d'absence exactement moi j o
j'étais en vacances pendant deux ans mon
grand retour aujourd'hui on va voir ça
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'est de ce talk
aujourd'hui émission spéciale sur les jo
de 2024 à paris coup de projecteur sur
les différents sites
yves binois qui ont été retenues dans le
dossier de candidature nous ferons
également un zoom sur les futures
pépites yvelinoise qui devrait à
participer à cet événement planétaire
mais tout de suite direction au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
[Musique]
on va tout de suite parlé du vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
structure inaugurée en janvier à 2014 va
accueillir les épreuves de cyclisme sur
piste pendant les jeux olympiques 2024
le site a déjà accueilli les
championnats du monde en 2015 également
les championnats d'europe
un an plus tard la question sur ce thème
le vélodrome at il fait ses preuves
organiser un tel événement vous votez
non fait un petit un petit duel entre le
pire le retour de basile contre contre
pierre basile
d'abord vous pouvez commenter avec moult
événements internationaux organisés
depuis son inauguration je pense que le
vélodrome a prouvé sa capacité à
accueillir ceux des événements d'ampleur
nationale internationale même si parfois
on a décrié la fluence qui n'était pas
son paroxysme sur c'est sur ces
événements mine de rien il ya toujours
eu de l'ambiance un public de
connaisseurs qui s'est rendu et de
belles courses
donc je pense que effectivement ça toute
sa place
le vélodrome a prouvé sa capacité à
accueillir cette idée pierre c'est à
vous je mets entre parenthèses la partie
purement sportive pour une fois dans
cette émission et 2
d'insister sur la partie plutôt
entertainment' spectacles et autres on
en a souvent parlé sur ce plateau le
vélodrome accueille désormais des
événements diversifié c'est évidemment
la raison d'être
le vélo et le cyclisme sur piste sur
différents événements de classe mondiale
mais peine à trouver un son régime de
croisière en terme d'affluence en termes
de nombre de spectateurs même si on voit
on voit certaines certaines images ici
même là avec avec les tribunes garnies
on en a vu beaucoup d'autres aussi
beaucoup de beaucoup d'autres reportages
ou le uss a sonné un petit peu plus
creux donc sportivement il faut être
faut être honnête et juste le vélodrome
est prêt parce qu'il a été
il a été construit pour ça il ya eu
quelques quelques événements classe
mondiale comme des championnats du monde
et puis tout ce qui est toute la cohorte
de championnats régionaux qui fait que
malgré tout prêts pour les jo ça me sens
il reste encore quelques années
enfin tout donc pas encore complètement
prêt dans la mue en termes de d'enceinte
capable d'être remplis à chaque achat qu
à chaque événement ça fait penser aussi
un petit peu à l'aréna de la défend de
la défense paris la défense arena qui
est d'abord une salle de spectacle avant
d'être une enceinte sportive en fait
finalement est là avec les dernières
actualités et activités du vélodrome
on a plus parlé des spectacles et des
sports autres qui étaient organisés les
événements qui était organisée au
vélodrome que de que de grandes
rencontres nationales internationale ou
régionale de cyclisme donc pas encore
prêt mais il reste largement
suffisamment de temps pour pour activer
un petit peu et affiner la communication
et parler au plus large possible pour
attirer des foules lors des jo 2000 24
je sais que vous bouillonner mais je
vais passer la parole d'abord à hélène
hélène qui vous a convaincu je rejoins
les
et les deux les deux mais c'est vrai que
d'un point de vue occupation on a j'ai
l'impression qu'il a été plus occupé par
des événements autre que le cyclisme que
que parcequ'il donc il a l'envergure il
a les possibilités mais par exemple un
événement crossfit 1 le week end du 28
et 29 29 et toulon avait il y avait du
monde il y avait pas mal de choses
durant à la gueule dans les années
précédentes avec le club d'issy paris
quitte ouais pareil 90 mhz et c'est vrai
que ce serait bien qu'il y ait plus de
communication plus de 2 de remplissage
de l'enceinte parce que l'enceinte le
mérite
elle mérite d'accueillir plus de monde
plus de manifestations et de voir plus
grand donc on espère que à voir les
choses soient déjà le cas et que suite
aux jets aux arènes à ça ça stimule pour
accueillir encore plus événement il ya
dujarrier notre spécialiste cyclisme
beaucoup d'éléments que je voulais dire
ont déjà été déjà des données le
vélodrome pour les jo de 2024 il a été
créé pour ça c'est à dire qu'il a vu là
ils essaient de seul sait le succès la
salle infrastructures qui est sorti
liées au dossier candidature pour les jo
de paris 2012
il était créée juste après parce que
monsieur sarkozy vous voulez à appuyer
le dossier très très fortement
donc voilà pour 2024 il était prévu que
les clés que les épreuves de cyclisme
sur piste soit soit au vélodrome
nationale je suis sûr qu'il sera rempli
à 100% pour les jo il ya aucun problème
puisque dès la première organisation des
championnats du monde
on avait fait foule tout le temps le
gros problème c'était sur des événements
un petit peu moins prestigieux ou là en
effet la communication pêche énormément
et donc
et donc du coup on parle que les
événements sportifs liés au cyclisme
parce que sur le crossfit
ils ont fait carton plein quand on
organise quand il organise une coupe
nationale sur du judo ou un championnat
national de judo c'est pareil le
vélodrome et blindés quand on les
organise du la gymnastique c'est pareil
c'est ces foules
et pourtant on n'est pas sur des grosses
catégories on est sur des plus des
catégories des plus jeunes
mais à chaque fois que cette du vélo au
vélodrome eh bien il ya personne alors
là je vais faire un appel rend bien sûr
on va tomber sur une période un petit
peu compliqué puisque ça va être la
première quinzaine
une grosse dizaine de jours sur la
première quinzaine du mois d'août mais
il va y avoir les championnats de france
qui vont être organisées au vélodrome 2
au vélodrome nationale avec un très très
gros plateau de sportifs français qui
vont venir pour aller chercher les
titres de champion de france et il faut
se déplacer parce qu'en plus c'est
l'entrée est gratuite
qui décide des dates les gens pleins de
france ça fait des années qu'ils sont
toujours organisés l'été parce qu'ils
sont organisées à guerre et sont
regroupés les catégories de cadets
jusqu'à seniors mais sa table voilà
parce que c'est quand même malgré tout
même si tous ne partent pas en vacances
exactement au même moment c'est quand
même c'est quand même pas mais toutes
ses chances de notre côté sur dur
d'organiser sur la région parisienne
c'est bien que ce moment où il ya le
moins de fabrique beaucoup d'enfants
sont partis sur à 70 organisations de
logistique mais bébé alors par quoi
l'allemagne jusqu'à hier à hier quand
ils se battent français et anglais sont
réalisés là-bas c'est rempli ses blindés
parce que les gens sont en vacances et
vienne et vienne une journée deux jours
pour pourvoir le championnat de france
et est donc ça permet de pouvoir réunir
sur ce championnat
les épreuves de cadets jusqu'à seniors
et donc de pouvoir faire une plus d'une
semaine complète sur le vélodrome moi je
participerai le vendredi et le samedi
en vitesse et en keirin donc là je vais
prendre une petite correction ou site
mais on donnera vos résultats dans ce
sens par l'histoire alors entre 11 et 12
août j'assume et je vais venir prendre
une petite une petite fessée parlée par
les grands champions mais ça va être
très très sympa de pouvoir s'aligner à
côté de hambourg où les jo il sera en
droit de julio aucun problème le
vélodrome est prêt il ay toute la
mécanique est prête pour accueillir la à
partir du moment où il ya des et la
notice organisé sur place
tout roule tout va comme sur des
roulettes la séquence de rejeter tout
roule voilà tout on tourne très bien
maintenant c'est toujours pour la
communication sur les événements moins
important on aura de toute façon d'ici
là je crois que ça fait de 2023
les championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste je pense qu'en signe mais
d'orienter la du monde un an avant les
jeux olympiques ses passions d'ivoire ça
fait partie du big sea rituel mais donc
n'ont aucun aucun problème le vélodrome
sera prêt puis revient purement
polémiques est ce que c'est en fonction
ce que tu dis est ce que c'est pas
est-ce que c'est pas le cyclisme sur
piste qui ne fait plus ou pas recette
est qui et qui a du mal à attirer le
public puisque le premier évidemment du
vélodrome nationale et et qu'il a du mal
à est rempli j'imagine que ailleurs en
fait c'est c'est le même si tu t'en
parle du batik cdu prometic française le
cyclisme n'attire pas puisque la seule
course
voilà toute la couverture médiatique est
prise par le tour de france donc ça dure
trois semaines pendant trois semaines on
pas que devait ne parle que de ça et
alors que en angleterre en angleterre le
moindre événement organisé
sur un vélodrome sur un vélodrome les
tribunes sont blindés à chaque fois de
même si ce sont des des événements comme
comme à je peux retrouver non mais bon
voilà des événements de chaud comme ils
peuvent en avoir l'hiver l'hiver là-bas
quoi les championnats du monde 2015 ont
été remplies mais par contre il est
comme un petit flop ans on peut dire
basile quand même sur les championnats
d'europe où il y avait seulement la
moitié du vélodrome qui étaient remplis
et encore la moitié je suis optimiste
quand je dis ça on vient c'était des
championnats d'europe à ce que 10 à ce
que diane c'est vrai qu'au niveau
communication on on a eu l'info sur ces
championnats d'europe
assez tardivement et la billetterie a
été lancée aussi très très tardivement
c'est peut-être ça ce qu'il a manqué sur
ces championnats d'europe c'est que dès
le début de d'année civile il pas
vraiment une communication qui soit fête
nationale mais aussi au niveau du
territoire au niveau des clubs le club
locaux pour pouvoir remplir et parce que
les champions qu'on roulait ce sont les
mêmes qui participent aux championnats
du monde les mêmes qui participent aux
jeux olympiques donc la couverture
médiatique elle doit vraiment se faire
sur sur cette tête d'affiché qu'on a en
france
lorsqu'un jour 1 2 puis il ya d'autres
championnats du monde du championnat
d'europe août organisées ailleurs et
maintenant je regarde un petit peu
comment commence à peine à se remplir
non non non ça reste quand même plus
difficile dans les airs championnats
d'europe
même chez les élites dans beaucoup de
temps beaucoup de pays c'est est ce que
je vais leur ds que c'est une question
de budget qui est pas attribués selon
les différentes
les différentes manifestations au
vélodrome pour la situation où elle est
au niveau 1 au niveau communication mais
a priori pas forcément puisque c'est
ceux qui fréquentent judo organise un
unkut n'a une coupe une coupe de france
pour les pour les jeunes au vélodrome
le vélodrome il est rempli à craquer et
et c'est parce que le judo fait des
places à 10 euros les 10 euros l'entrée
et donc du coup bah c'est facile c'est
facile d'accès pour pour tout le monde
faut pas faire faut pas le nier quand
comme vous voyez des inscriptions où il
faut payer entre 20 et 25 euros pour par
personne quand vous venez avec monsieur
madame le petit gars fin à monsieur et
puis les deux enfants voilà c'est quand
des sorties à 100 euros après avoir jeté
le pique nique vous rajoutez sais pas
c'est pas si simple pour venir sur une
seule journée
il faut il faut baisser les coûts et
parce que c'est passé sont faciles oui
mais oui il vaut mieux remplir à dix
bals et avoir avoir 5000 personnes dans
le vélodrome
plutôt que de l'être à la moitié a moins
de la moitié à 25 euros vous avez au
profit du coup ces problèmes de les
discipliner le même qui fait pas recette
hulu le le fait que ça soit en indoor en
indoor par exemple parce que ça lui met
des gifles et une grande parce que
justement notre sens mais par rapport
aux par rapport au tour de france où
comme vous venez vous allez attendre
pendant trois heures pour voir passer la
caravane
et puis il y voir passer pendant une
minute avec voilà toute la journée
c'est pendant la vie vous voyez toute la
course
quand quand vous avez une course aux
points vous
vous pouvez suivre la totalité il faut
mettre il faut mettre un petit peu
avertis pour ne pas couper
l'émission doit avancer viennent de
jarrier noront continue à parler de
cyclisme on va parler notamment de la
colline d'hallencourt donc le vélodrome
ne sera pas le seul site à accueillir
les épreuves la colline est en cours à
recevoir les épreuves de vtt pendant les
jo un site qui accueille régulièrement
des compétitions notamment la
revancharde un rendez vous organisé
depuis 21 ans sur les lieux le site
méritent ils d'être olympique nous avons
posé la question aux participants
pendant la revanche et quand on a su la
décision du du cio comme quoi c'était
placé comme site pour les journées
étaient contents contents de nous parce
qu'on la fait vivre très vieux plus
difficultés je pense pour les olympiens
mais sinon en soit c'est super et les
avantages de ce parcours c'est qu'il ya
des très gros dénivelés et des très
belles parties techniques
donc c'est vraiment un parcours qui est
très très compliqué les épreuves de golf
seront quant à elles organisées sur le
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines incident qui a
déjà accueilli la ryder cup en 2018 et
qui vend la coupe du monde du golf
la question sur ce thème les lieux sont
il judicieux pour organiser ces épreuves
oui de thunes animent des jeux suivante
pourquoi je pense que ça a fait ses
preuves
si les les organisateurs le décide et
aussi les participants acquiesce pour
moi c'est que ça doit se passer là les
capacités les caractéristiques chez
super chaud pour les oui oui c'est ça
c'est l'été sur plateau non mais pour
moi ça a tout à fait sa place
des trans et olympique donc on ne remet
pas en cause la décision des
organisateurs
basile alors moi je compléterai en
disant que la colline est en cours n'a
pas encore totalement fait ses preuves
au niveau d'hier internationale parce
que pour l'instant ça reste une épreuve
d'ordre national qui a été organisée
cette épreuve
voilà mais c'est sympa c'est un pari
c'est un pari que faire le comité
national olympique de miser sur sur la
colline elle encourt un choix je pense
de proximité géographique avec les
autres épreuves cyclistes qui vont se
passer donc comme on a dit au vélodrome
ou pour la course sur route en tout cas
en région parisienne donc il ya un choix
il ya un pôle cyclisme en tout cas dans
les yvelines
c'est clairement c'est clairement je
pense le critère le critère numéro un
qui a fait que c'est la colline
elancourt qui a été qu'il était choix
qui a été choisi et je pense que c'est
un parcours qui va ressembler
sensiblement ce qu'on a eu à rio c'est
pour ceux qui ont regardé un peu le vtt
à rio un parcours comme comme l'expliqué
un concurrent avec beaucoup de dénivelé
je pense et qui va être plus assez casse
pattes je pense serre-chevalier
j'ai bien sûr parlé principalement de
golf mais mais juste sur la partie
coline d'elancourt là aussi on en a
souvent travaillé sur ce que sur le
plateau là le les yvelines sont une
terre de cyclisme ont parlé de on parler
de ce qu'ils surent sur piste mais aussi
sur route ce temps sur tout l'est sur
toutes les routes de la vallée de
chevreuse et l'assuré sur un sur un
dénivelé qui a un tracé qui a fait ses
preuves sur cette épreuve là c'est tout
à fait tout à fait judicieux et c'est
très bien qu'on est plusieurs épreuves
dans les yvelines d'ailleurs quand on
récolte nationale alors là mais
qu'est-ce que qu est ce qu on pourrait
ajouter à la la capacité du golf
national à accueillir les jeux
olympiques
je ne dirais pas que le golf national a
été fait pour les jeux olympiques mais
il a été fait pour des événements de
classe mondiale il accueille l'open de
france depuis des années la plus près
d'une vingtaine d'années avec succès il
ya une parenthèse sur cette année où on
change de date et on a un petit peu plus
d'inquiétudes et d'interrogations sur
l'affluent de passation s'est organisé
la dernière semaine de juin et sera
organisée mi octobre en au top cette
année c'est un servette une année un
petit peut-être une année de transition
mais alors quand on regarde quand on
regarde encore dans le rétro avec la
ryder cup 2018
ce fantastique événement international
qui a accueilli jusqu'à 70 mille
personnes jours
je crois que non seulement il est prêt
même seul j'avais lu en france et jamais
vu en france il a été fait pour ce genre
d'événement grâce à grâce à sa
topographie et c'est assez but qui
entoure les greens et qui permet de voir
bien partout mais je pense en plus de
son côté judicieux pertinent près ça va
être aussi une totale nouveauté pour le
golf olympique
bon déjà c'est ça ne fait jamais que que
depuis une édition qu'il est redevenu
olympique depuis depuis le début du
siècle dernier rio mais il y avait pas
grand monde sur le sur le parcours de
rio parce qu'il ya pas beaucoup de
golfeurs au brésil
voilà avec la france les golfeurs
français le développement attendu et la
ryder cup accueillant 2018 ça va être
une grosse nouveauté il y aura de
l'affluence sur une discipline sur une
épreuve de vos jeux olympiques il ya
déjà riez qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous de la colline de l'encours et du
golf national de saint-quentin alors
comme disait basile c'est vrai que l'
avantage de la conel en cours c'est
qu'on va pouvoir faire un parcours un
peu comme rio londres ous avez été des
parcours vraiment
calibré et dessiné pour pour le
spectacle et pour le pour l'épreuve
olympique pin donc on aura quelque chose
de kiva qui va aider l'egypte est l'aîné
enfin merci un truc télégénique ça va
être ça va être top
et puis et puis voilà c'est bien de
regrouper toutes les épreuves de
cyclisme parce que sur sur la quinzaine
ben voilà il y aura toujours un ou deux
jours ou pour aller voir enfin vous
pouvez aller voir du vélo très très
régulièrement un peu un petit peu
partout et pas du tout pas du tout pas
du tout maintenant parce que il n'y a
pas assez de bois il n'y a pas assez il
ya plein de bois mais y'a pas ses
planches pour pouvoir
ouais je suis pas faite dès que le temps
plus mais n'ont pu mat et était tout
simplement donc donc c'est pas du tout
un parcours qui est vain un endroit qui
m'attire mais je viens très souvent au
vélodrome
voilà non on a on a chacun sait n'ont
donc jamais jamais un petit tour un
petit tour sur la colline et mais là par
contre pour voir les produits d'été
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qui
peut être qui peut être sympa à
condition qu'on ait des français qu'ils
soient compétitifs et
et c'est pas le cadre dernièrement à
avoir avoir dans les quatre dernières
années mais ça l'est pour l'instant sur
le vtt c'est un peu plus compliqué il ya
un suisse sous leurs mains truc comme ça
là qui dominent la discipline l'unc et
un peu qui est un peu l'homme à abattre
voilà en tout cas le parcours vous plaît
mais le parcours sera de toute façon
très très très très bien il sera
suffisamment techniques suffisamment de
dénivelé ça va être ça va être un cheval
pour le jeu pour le golf ou ajouté qu'
avec la ryder cup qui s'est déroulée
l'année dernière tout dépendra du mode
de sélection des équipes des équipes
olympiques mais on risque d'avoir mûri
ce qu'on aura la chance d'avoir aussi
quelques têtes d'affiché parce qu'ils
l'ont fait déjà des repérages et ils ne
rechigneront pas à pouvoir s'aligner sur
une compétition certes amateur olympique
mais on peut avoir quelques têtes
d'affiché qui vont aller se battre pour
prendre le titre de justin rose le
dernier champion olympique hommes alors
je vous vois quand même très
enthousiaste un autre date à vous avez
tous voté oui bien sûr pour les sites
olympiques
il ya quand même un petit bémol la
colline elancourt fait donc plus de 230
mètres de haut mais par contre c'est
artificiel
parce que ce sont les gravats de
l'ancienne ville nouvelle qui ont été
déplacés jusqu'à sept collines
d'elancourt pour en faire le site que
culminant d'île de france basile c'est
pas par un petit bémol quand même qu'il
faut ajouter la question que je viens
aujourd'hui voilà c'est un espace assez
devenu un espace un espace naturel
aujourd'hui
non non plus j'ai jamais mis les pieds
alors du mal à m'exprimer totalement
dessus mais aujourd'hui quand on voit
les images l'acquis qui passe c'est
devenu vraiment un espace de weert de
verdure et je pense que les personnes
qui sont pas du coin sont loin
d'imaginer que c'était autrefois une
seulement une pleine et qui a servi à
construire la ville nouvelle et que ce
sont les gravats de la construction de
la ville nouvelle de saint quentin
ce serait bien ce serait bien d'en
parler et puis voilà c'est pas non plus
un espace polluer 1
non non ce n'est pas grave voilà c'est
pas donc des démolitions qui ont été
regroupés un mois je ne savais pas pour
la colline elancourt mais pour le coach
national c'est exactement la même chose
c'est que c'est une
c'est une réhabilitation de gravats ont
fait de différence de différents
matériaux récupérés sur des chantiers au
départ avec un modelage qui a été fait
qu ensuite de l'intérieur de la terre
végétale au dessus de ces gravats là
qu'il faut voir après une habile
écologique mais trentaine d'années c'est
que justement c'est devenu un site
naturel préservé faune flore justement
mise en avant
alors oui il faut pas creuser faut pas
creuser à 30 mètres on voit ce qu'il ya
dessous est désormais désormais c'est
une c'est toute une zone est tout un
tout un ensemble de matériaux qui ont
été réhabilités et qui donne un lieu
naturel et préservé pour un parcours de
golf à proximité de l'agglomération
une dernière question sur le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
ryder cup est organisée principalement
par l'european tour
donc les anglais qu'est ce que vous
pensez qu'il y aura la même organisation
pour les jo de 2024
moi je pense que alors sa part
évidemment sera pas les mêmes personnes
sera pas exactement les mêmes là même
les négatifs maintenant mais la garantie
la garantie principale ce sont les
équipes du golf national autour de
autour de polars mitage
et de tous et de tous ses acteurs et
directeur national qui à qui il va je
pense garder on espère la majeure partie
de ses effectifs qui ont qui ont fait
leurs preuves dans l'organisation alors
certes qui était qui était bien bien
cornaqué par les britanniques les anglo
saxons les américains mais mais qui
désormais
ils ont à leur actif l'organisation
réussie et dieu sait qu'elle a été
réussie de la ryder cup 2010 eden
vous êtes optimiste également une image
aux optimistes optimiste sur le golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
et puis franchement je pense qu'on s'en
fiche que ce soit fait par des gras avec
des gravats ou d'arrivée de la
réhabilitation
comme on le disait lors d une
organisation anglaise
oui d'ailleurs optimisme associations
sont en train de mourir de chaud le
savoir pour l'anecdote lens annoncé le
parquet par le cio les golfeurs et les
cyclistes ne logeront pas au village
olympique logeront sur la vie dans la
vie nouvelle dans les environs dans les
yeux qu'il y ait des hôtels qui ont été
déterminées par le cio dans le coin qui
permettront de loger golfeurs et
cyclistes pour leur éviter de faire tous
les jours l'aller-retour avec leur a
vraiment pour tout ficelé golf hall 6
voilà cyclistes et golf dans les
yvelines et donc je pense que même les
spectateurs auront peut-être l'occasion
de croiser dans la rue en bas de leur
hôtel aux abords des équipements
sportifs
peut-être tiger woods peut-être comme si
comme c'est toujours le cas lors d'un
championnat du monde des bras l'a alors
des grandes des grandes têtes d'affiché
un peu plus compliqué mais il n'y a pas
plu autant qu'en fin mai et mi juin je
me suis promené
porte de saint-cloud j'avais un
rendez-vous avant avant roland garros
et vous voyez déjà les tennismans qui se
promènent avec leur sac et vous savez
pas qui c'est mais vous savez qu'ils
sont là pour jouer au tennis que ces
attaques et vous avez vu nadal je crois
on espère que ça sera que l'effet
domestique va jouer et que les français
qui sont les français et les françaises
qui sont sélectionnés sur le cyclisme ou
pour le golf puisse être faire comme à
la maison et avoir peut-être un avantage
sur les autres on va passer maintenant à
notre page coup de projecteur on passe
maintenant notre prochaine thématique si
certains sites ont été à confirmer
d'autres sont encore avec des points
d'interrogation c'est le cas des courses
sur route qui devrait normalement se
dérouler dans la vallée de chevreuse
mais les organisateurs voudraient du
bling bling et un passage proche des
monuments de paris
le bmx à saint quentin en yvelines ce
n'est pas certain non plus la piste
actuelle n'est pas adapté une piste
provisoire sera construite dans l'île
des loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
certaines voix se sont élevées pour en
construire une mais un autre endroit
dans la région parisienne
la question sur ce thème comprenez vous
ces incertitudes
oui ou non oui oui oui on pas de débat
encore une fois bien dujarrier tout
simplement la piste de bmx c'est eu là
une très belle piste de bmx manque de
bol il ya un toit il ya un toit dessus
et donc ça ne rentre pas dans les
critères olympiques il faut que ce soit
une piste découverte pour les pour les
jeux olympiques donc voilà alors faire
une à saint quentin en yvelines
moi je vais être un peu chauvin et je
dis oui il faut que ça reste il faut ça
reste dans le coin parce que attention
ça sera une piste démontable je suis en
merabet ville et protéger protéger les
yeux ça serait aussi très bien si c'est
une piste une piste démontable sont des
choses que que des entreprises sont
capables de faire et pas avec des coûts
trop pas trop important non plus donc
voilà la halle
tribune que l'on voit là elle est aussi
s'est-il tribunes démontables sur le
seul site de saint quentin en yvelines
ne reste que là que l'api de bmx
donc voilà s'il faut s'il faut refaire
une piste un peu plus loin c'est pas
catastrophique c'est pas c'est pas un
gros gros problème
après oui dresser dans cet esprit où on
se dit voilà tous les sites ou des
épreuves de cyclisme reste dense entre
18 et on essaie de les mettre à ces
groupes et ben je pense que ça c'est je
pense que c'est plutôt malin et et puis
après bien sûr que pour la pour la
vallée de chevreuse moi je suis je suis
fan à 200%
j'aimerais suivre le cyclisme sur route
sur ses textures ou très bien sûr mais
j'aimerais juste une chose c'est que
c'est sur le parcours
ils prennent ils prennent la côte de la
côte de la madeleine château de la
madeleine qui est une des plus pentue
dans le dans les yvelines et en plus
être très étroite donc elle permettrait
de faire une petite sélection parce
qu'elle est quand même assez courte mais
mais voilà il ya vraiment moyen de faire
des choses sympas et ensuite pour les
volets malécot temps rappelle pas pour
moi mais pour les copains je suis de la
route ils ont l'habitude ça va c'est pas
grave chacun ses problèmes
après bien sûr qu'il faut aussi faire un
peu de bling bling mais on se souvient
de londres où une son parti de
buckingham avec un retour à buckingham
et puis une épreuve une épreuve dans la
campagne londonienne et ils sont arrivés
à 2 pour le pour le tri tc alexander
vinokourov qui remporte voilà une belle
course et c'est pas parce que c'est pas
parce que on va être obligé d'aller
faire un tour au louvre et donc les
faire partir de paris le tour de france
le fait tous les ans c'est à dire partir
de la région parisienne pour aller venir
finir venir finir sur dans le centre de
paris
voilà c'est quelque chose qu'on est
largement capable de faire tous les ans
au mois de juillet donc là au mois
d'août
on sera aussi capable de le faire donc
pourquoi pas faire un départ en plein
centre de paris
une petite parade pendant pendant une
heure dans paris et puis ensuite on
rejoint la vallée de chevreuse ont fait
la course
et puis l'arrivée devant le château de
versailles par exemple après avoir après
être passé dans la minière s'ils veulent
des idées je suis numéro de téléphone
c'est le ellen est ce que vous êtes pour
aussi ce mix entre les deux oui j'aime
bien et puis j'aime aussi l'idée que ça
reste
dans dans les yvelines après comme
disait jan
paris a déjà gérer ce genre de 2
comment dire de d'étape de départ
d'arrivée donc
oui après la vallée de chevreuse le
château de versailles a très bon edel
château de versailles en puissance en
août
voilà il ya un petit peu moins pour tout
le monde il ya suffisamment suffisamment
dangereux suffisamment de d'engouement
pour les jeux olympiques pour pouvoir
couvrir tout le territoire
je parle france entière et il faut vous
faut que les l'ensemble de l'île de
france puisse être puisse être sollicité
je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre de
villes qui ont fait acte de candidature
justement pour pouvoir participer à cet
effort olympique et à cette belle fête
que devront être les jeux olympiques 24
donc c'est tout à fait normal qui est
certaine dossier certains dossiers en
balance parce que justement il ya déjà
un certain nombre de beaux événements
qui sont confirmés dans les yvelines que
d'autres puissent faire acte de
candidature et qu'on ait une diversité à
la fois des villages des routes et des
villes traversées en plus avec le côté
carte postale touristique parce qu'il
faut que la france reste justement cette
destination numéro un au monde et grâce
à ces événements sportifs internationaux
elle aura plus de facilités de le faire
surtout si elles m'ont aussi elle montre
l'ensemble de ces de ses atouts et de
son catalogue touristique et culturel
grégory vous si vous comprenez ces
situations ces incertitudes
ben elles sont elles sont là aussi parce
que il ya une incertitude qui règne
encore sur qu'yvette ce prestataire de
services pour ces épreuves de cyclisme
sylviane je me trompe à etsaut va
candidater et la ffc qui souhaitent
également donc en fait ils se retrouvent
tous se retrouvèrent en face de l'autre
à etsaut con qu'on connaît que voilà qui
organise le tour de france et la
fédération qui aimerait justement être
le prestataire de service lors des jeux
forcément pour l'image
donc on sa dette mettre du temps avant
que le voile de cette incertitude sur le
tracé qu'on peut envisager en ile de
france
normalement la célébration a déjà
proposé un tracé qui partirait de
rambouillet pour arriver sur les
champs-elysées en passant par la vallée
de chevreuse mais pour l'instant ce n'a
pas été validé à temps que l'inversé la
livre le choix ne sera pas fait par le
com
olympique du prestataire on n'aura pas
de 10 des vraiment du tracé à mon avis
qui sera décidé que un an avant il faut
être un drame
il faut attendre je pas dire le plus
tard possible pour dessiner le tracé
mais il faut attendre parce que ce
serait bien d'organiser une épreuve
pré-olympique dessus quand même voilà
comme ça avait été fait pour pour rio
qui avait été remporté par un français
en plus je me souviens mais mais c'est
vrai que
il faut attendre parce que on sait
comment ça se passe en france il ya
toujours des travaux à droite à gauche
etc et donc du coup être sûr que les uns
face et j'ai surtout été voilà donc être
sûr que les infrastructures seront
accessibles et seront possibles donc il
faut il faut attendre pour dessiner le
parcours de la course sur route
maintenant voilà on a largement le temps
et en effet je pense que s'ils avaient
ou pouvaient dire on est peut-être un
petit peu gourmand sur l'histoire et ont
laissé un peu à la fédé pour une fois ça
pourrait être ça pourrait être mal hein
c'est pas sûr ça se passe comme ça
maintenant quand on quand on a un bateau
comme ça on en veut toujours à bureaux
bien sûr moi je vais très bien une pièce
sur départ et arrivée dans le centre de
paris
j'avais entendu parler d'un départ quai
branly une arrivée tour eiffel et
ensuite un passage par château de
versailles et descendre dans la vallée
de chevreuse je suis pas juge et partie
du malentendu marathon qui fait la fait
le même
je suis passé je jouais pas je suis
capable de dire arriver arrivé sur sur
les champs elysées c'est déjà cac win en
mai par rapport au projet de la fft
depuis je vais parler voilà déjà léger
tous les ans c'est déjà fait tous les
ans avec le tour de france
justement trouvé une petite idée pour
faire autre chose ça peut être aussi la
butte montmartre pour parler les gens de
rambouillet bon cette année oui ça
partira de renvoyer ses cousines ans se
faire faire une arrivée faire une
arrivée après une belle course de 250
bornes dans la
pour monter au sacré coeur ça peut être
ça peut être bien sympa et bien casse
pattes
au final donc voilà il ya plein de
possibilités c'est vrai que paris est
varié et gigantesque paris est très très
beau et donc il ya eu plein de choses à
faire quoi le bmx pierre chevalier une
nouvelle piste qui sera construite il ya
celle de m de son passé quoi c'est en
mètres plus loin il ya celle que pas
loin déjà existantes après c'est le doit
y avoir aussi une connotation données
budget aussi pour l'ensemble du dossier
pouvoir utiliser les infrastructures
existantes
après diversifiée en crée des nouvelles
pour aller un petit peu plus près parce
que c'est juste qu'on pose problème je
le rappelle c'est juste toi mais c'est
pour des prises d'imagés rien là pour le
cas concret du bmx
il ya des il ya une structure existante
qui est qui et pas très loin
là ça serait peut-être peut-être moins
judicieux mais à voir si si le à la fois
le budget est l'enjeu l'enjeu
touristique médiatique et ou de
communications locales peut faire
basculer serré c'est dommage d'avoir mis
un toit alors que c'était prévu pour
pourrais-tu région d'almaty qu on passe
à la prochaine thématique le comité
paris 2024 vient de lancer
officiellement le label terre de jeux
2024 qui doit permettre à toutes les
collectivités locales volontaires de
participer à l'aventuré olympique c'est
une première on imagine que
saint-quentin divine ou bien sûr
versailles vont postuler pour la voir il
n'est pas question d'argent ce label
mais d'actions les collectivités
retenues pour recevoir un kit de
communication avec le logo des objets
dérivés et des exemples d'actions à
mener la question sur ce thème ce label
va t'il servir oui ou non n'ont pas
d'argent
la communication enfin petit duel entre
vous et lemm et pierre ducout yen est
très partagé pourquoi il ne pense que ça
va servir en termes d'identification
de marketing de publicité oui on peut
pas dire ça ça va servir à rien mais
d'un point de vue même pour les mêmes
pour les entreprises de se faire un peu
plus connaître de diffuser de touche et
peut-être du monde
de ce point de vue là je pense que voilà
ces deux conduits là que ça va servir
après est-ce que ça va avoir des gros
impact je pense que ça va dépendre de
quelle entreprise
la bella est ce que ça va toucher que
des grosses entreprises des petites
entreprises les éviter plutôt au niveau
des villes c'est un peu comme villes et
villages fleuris par exemple point
commune
oui après je pense que oui voilà il ya
forcément l'utilité après on va voir à
quel point mes chercheurs pensent que
c'est une strate une strate de
communication et les strates de
marketing qui n'est pas suffisamment
actuellement et d'ici là pas
suffisamment bien défini autant une
ville qui accueille des épreuves a
clairement a clairement déjà une volonté
affichée sur le sur l'esprit olympique
et sur le sur l'organisation et sur la
volonté de réussir de réussir être
participer à l'événement une
collectivité qui veut simplement se dire
se dire fans des jo où justement
participants au moins dans l'esprit à
l'esprit à l'esprit olympique je trouve
ça je trouve ça a sauvé à ce stade un
peu trop léger et de de ne pas de ne pas
concevoir que qu'ils puissent y est dit
que toutes les collectivités par
définition soit déjà soit déjà
intéressés par les jeux et déjà et déjà
volontaires pour pour faire en sorte de
pouvoir montrer le meilleur visage de la
france je ne pense pas qu'il y ait
besoin d'un label pour pouvoir le second
le sanctionner le et le prouver pour les
collectivités qui sont qui sommes
concernés
après ça peut quand même fédérer donc
voir celles qui sont un peu légère qui
manque un peu de motivation qui savent
pas quoi faire le fait d'être rassemblés
sous un label ça peut guider ça peut
permettre que les décharges voile à
partir de l'année 2020 les collectivités
labellisées devront être présents sur
trois temps forts la semaine olympique à
l'école la journée olympique du 23 juin
et les jo de tokyo avec notamment la
mise en place de d'événements de
d'écrans géants pour
pour promouvoir donc ses tresses être un
rôle est justement cet esprit olympique
dès 2020 jusqu'à la montée 2024 je pense
que naturellement naturellement les
collectivités peuvent être peuvent être
versés justement vers l'esprit olympique
sans avoir forcément besoin du label en
revanche le côté développement dans les
milieux scolaires ça c'est ça c'est un
fait c'est un élément intéressant ça
peut valoir largement à lui seul
justement ce le ce label ou cette
volonté affichée par les collectivités
basile rigoler oui je reviens à rebondir
justement sur ce que pierre vient de
dire sans même encore avoir postulé pour
le label la ville de versailles organise
déjà des journées olympie la journée
olympique depuis maintenant trois ans
accueille durant toute une semaine des
élèves des écoles primaires pour
justement déjà leur faire partager les
valeurs de l'olympisme
il ya eu une exposition qui a été fait
sur les sur les jeux olympiques donc
voilà il ya déjà des efforts qui sont
faits sans même attendre que ce label
arrive ça se trouve il serait jamais
arrivé les mêmes efforts auraient été
aurait été fait mais c'est vrai qu'on
sent au sein des coliques collectivités
et encore plus celle qui vont accueillir
des épreuves qui veille avec chaque
année il ya une marche qui est passé une
sorte de montée en puissance qui va voir
aller dans ce sens-là jusqu'à jusqu'à
2024 pour que ce soit vraiment relayé au
sein de la population du plus jeune ou
plus âgé il ya dix jarrier donne la
parole après on passera la prochaine
thématique henvic c'est vous qui terminé
toutes les thématiques depuis tout à
l'heure c'est parce que j'en ai pas là
donc
simplement merci il faut que vous soyez
tous qu'ils soient répéter tous les ans
jusqu'à jusqu'à la finalité pas juste se
dire bon sur 2020 on met l'accent pour
les jo de les jo de tokyo
par contre et je vais rappeler quelque
chose c'est quand même les jeux
olympiques seront organisées en 2024 à
paris au mois d'août
donc ce label peut peut-être servir pour
des communes et s'assure n'est peut-être
sur les dernières années sur des
communes
balnéaire où justement ils pourront
organiser crémer des écrans géants place
organisé des ddd tournoi olympique pour
que les gens viennent et se regroupent
comme quand on est sur une coupe du
monde et surtout pour pouvoir voir les
épreuves olympiques ça c'est quelque
chose auquel il faudra y penser parce
que c'est vrai que tout le monde ne sera
pas à paris
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont rien à
des jeux olympiques faux pas ne
faut pas le mot qu'il faut pas garder
sur le plateau personne bien sûr qu'ils
continueront qui partiront en vacances
au mois d'août
moi je sais ce que je ferai en 2024 avec
mes enfants au mois d'août et je
prendrai mes enfants en vacances pour sa
part ce que parce que c'est vrai que je
veux leur faire découvrir vraiment ce
qu'est ce qu'est l'esprit olympique est
ce que sont les épreuves olympiques
différents et la différence qui pourrait
y avoir par rapport aux championnats du
monde auxquels on peut voir tous les ans
ou tous les deux ans selon les selon les
sports ne me coupait pas et rapidement
vous avez dix grands et l'objectif c'est
ensuite de pouvoir continuer d'aller à
los angeles pour pourvoir aussi des jeux
olympiques en 2008 avec on passe
maintenant notre page débats après la
séquence voyage doyenne du jarrier dans
cette tâche des balles nous allons
parler du sportif nous avons beaucoup
parlé des infrastructures mais là nous
allons parler du sportif les jo de 2024
se prépare dès à présent pour les jeunes
pépites yvelinoise nous en avons recensé
au minimum 4 dans les yvelines les
cyclistes sur piste rien elle almaty de
gros et sébastien viger et en bmx jérémy
rencurel et réalise tous les podiums
internationaux sur les plus grandes
compétitions ces dernières années la
compéti la question sur ce thème faut-il
déjà les préparer oui
basile vous avez été le premier à
dégainer bien sûr bien sûr que ceux qui
vont à tokyo l'an prochain on sait déjà
c'est déjà 99,9 pour cent qui seront les
sportifs préparer une carrière c'est
long une carrière c'est long et préparer
des jeux olympiques
c'est un travail qui peut prendre quatre
à quatre à huit années dès qu'une
olympiades commence
certains sont déjà focus sur sur les
quatre années à venir
donc c'est ce qui va se passer un deck
tokyo sera terminé si ce n'est même
maintenant certains ont déjà paris dans
le viseur sa demande de passer
différentes étapes dont sont dans son
processus de performance
de valider à travers des championnats
nationaux internationaux prendre de
l'expérience aller s'aguerrir faire des
stages à l'étranger
tout ça se prépare sur plusieurs années
si on souhaite déjà un ce qualifier
parce que tout le monde n'y va pas et
ensuite être performant être performant
là bas donc sa demande de s'y préparer
dès maintenant vous êtes d'accord
oui dès maintenant c'est vrai on le sait
mais on sait que de toute façon ça prend
du temps comme il le disait il ya
plusieurs comment dire plusieurs étapes
de deux championnats validés avant
plusieurs catégories de championnat donc
2024 2028
ça arrive vite et je pense qu'on va
croiser à peu près les mêmes personnes
sur sur les deux tout les petits jeunes
qui sont en sortir qu ils font déjà
leurs preuves
on va les croisés sur ces huit années
qui sont en train d'arriver donc ils
vont pouvoir aussi de même suivre le
résultat sur c'est sur ces années là
donc une première étape arrivera des
petites étapes allons une première étape
en 2024 puis 2028
là c'est un petit peu le gros de leur
carrière c'est maintenant donc on va les
suivre sur chevalet qu'un atout qui ce
qui se travaille avec le temps c'est
l'expérience est là en l'occurrence est
à 8
on fonce des olympiades 8 ou quatre en
quatre ans pour préparer ils n'auront
pas besoin de motivation supplémentaire
avec des jeux des jeux olympiques qui
sont sur le territoire français a trouvé
en revanche la s'aguerrir et être
compétitif face aux meilleurs en 2024 ça
se prépare
le plus tôt possible au clan
l'occurrence oui dès maintenant de
manière à se frotter aux meilleurs sur
les sur tout les toutes les compétitions
quel que soit le niveau que ce soit mais
justement acquérir de l'expérience se
connaître se connaître soi même que les
de ses forces et faiblesses essayer de
travailler les deux justement pour être
pour être prêt prêt au moment où le
départ sera donné
selon les disciplines après yann est ce
qu'il faut peut-être les garder un petit
peu sous couveuse ainsi je peux dire
plutôt que de les lancer tout de suite
dans le grand bain ils ont énormément de
pression sur les deux trois années qui
vont précéder les jo de 2024
est-ce qu'il faut pas les garder un
petit peu pour l'instant en retrait et
les laisse sortir d'aller moment voilà
c'est pareil ça va dépendre de l'âge et
de la maturation jamais rencurel 24 ans
mathilde de gros 20 ans rien n'est là le
20 ans sébastien vigier 22 ans et donc
donc ça veut dire 28 ans et voir 29 ans
pour pour le bmx pour jérémy ensuite les
les pistards eux ils auront 24 25
c'est maintenant c'est il faut qu'ils
doivent être à rio et paris où il avait
tout japon pardon pour pour prendre une
première expérience et pour être au top
parce que un événement olympique c'est
pas la même chose qu'un championnat du
monde c'est encore une étape au dessus
et tu disais tout à l'heure vous avez
des sportifs qui sont champions
olympiques et quand ils finissent les
jeux olympiques et ben ils prennent un
an de coupure pour vider la tête
je vais prendre l'exemple de teddy riner
en france qui va en est maintenant à sa
quatrième extrait à sa 4ème olympiades
au japon et il est quand même et il est
illégitime favori et il veut vraiment
être champion olympique au japon et il
revient maintenant à un an et demi d un
an des jeux là il est compétitif et il
reprend et il reprend il recommence mais
books voilà tout ça c'est une
préparation c'est à dire que je souffre
parce que la charge d'entraînement et il
se met qu'il se met l'année près olympe
l'année la deûle année préolympique et
bien c'est juste quelque chose que
quelques lui qui est capable de le
bouffer donc il a besoin de prendre des
vacances et de souffler et de répondre
aux médias aussi parce que hilali n'a il
a besoin de vivre de son de 2 de son
sport ensuite ben voilà c'est trois en
un an et demi de travail foncier après
un an et demi où il va exploser et il va
être encore phénoménale et je vais
prendre aussi l'exemple de
jason kenny en cyclisme sur piste
londres il est champion olympique
on ne voit pas pendant un an et demi rio
il est champion olympique
il avait été jugé champion du monde
l'année date dans la dans l'année parce
que les championnats du monde est
organisée à londres
sinon ils l'auraient pas été champion du
monde donc vouloir recommandé d'avoir
une année sabbatique après les yeux de
tokyo ils sont plus jeunes nous ils sont
plus jeunes de jeunes
mais s'ils ont besoin de souffler après
après après le japon il faudra qu'ils
souffrent
ryan ryan ça fait quand même ça fait
quand même deux trois ans maintenant
qu'il est qu'il est à saint quentin et
pour le voir pour l'avoir vu évoluer sur
les deux dernières années
je rigole pas l'entraînement sébastien
c'est pareil moi je le sais parce que je
le connais c'est pas s'infliger je le
connais depuis depuis qu'il cadets et
voilà la volumétrie le ski mais qui
passe à l'écran est la volumétrie voilà
c'est bien servi j'ai la volonté qu'il a
pris ça se fait pas tout seul c'est une
hygiène de vie c'est cette demande
énormément de sacrifices
et bien tout ça en effet le plus tôt
c'est le met bien sûr et la pression
basile pour vous impressionner sera pas
trop intense de les mettre déjà dans
cette optique géo 2024
si on n'est pas capable dès maintenant
supporter une pression quotidienne
annuel avec 2 mal engagée par exemple
est programmé pour gagner une médaille
aux jo de 2024
bien sûr mais ça c'est les médias qui
attendent beaucoup mais nous français on
attend on attend demain on attend
beaucoup mais le potentiel est là les
résultats sont ce qu'elle fait pour pour
son âge laisse espérer évidemment une
médaille à tokyo à paris et ce n'est pas
la plus belle qui s'en est bien juste de
prendre une médaille d'argent sur la
vitesse au jeu européen à minsk voilà
donc ryan a également deux médailles
d'argent également mêlé d'argent je
perdais pas des pièces par équipe parce
que aujourd'hui prendre de la vitesse
par équipes c'est que il ya les
hollandais qui domine kitty archi-dominé
ressort avec deux médailles d'or et aimé
par contre sur youtube ce qu'il a fait
sur le terrain ça a été génial quoi il a
su couru au plus juste épreuve olympique
voilà elle m'a dit ryan c'est là-dessus
faut que tu bosses
ces bassins vigier n'était pas à minsk
ces bassins budget est normalement un
poil un poil un poil plus fort donc ça
laisse entrevoir de belles choses pour
pour ces jeunes qui sont qui sont en
pleine bourre
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler dans
les prochaines années on a encore cinq
ans on passe maintenant notre page
découverte
dans cette page est découverte nous
allons parler de quatre nouveaux sports
qui vont intégrer les ces jeux
olympiques en 2024
le breakdance le surf le skateboard et
l' escalade vont être retenu pour
l'édition parisienne des surprises comme
pour le break dance mais également des
confirmations l'escaladent sera déjà aux
jo de tokyo en 2020 la question sur ce
thème faut-il proposer d'en organiser
dans les yvelines breakdance
voilà l'une des quatre où les quatre
cordes escalade
j'ai pas trop des services de loisirs
saint quentin ville pourquoi pas donc
pierre non je peux tout pour accrocher
ce qu'on disait avons un il en faut pour
tout le monde de les disciplines phares
et les disciplines maîtresse en dans les
yvelines
on les a cités avec des sites qui sont
qui sont historiquement culturellement
les depuis longtemps prêt à accueillir
ce genre d'événement là il ya l'aspect
nouveauté l'aspect originalité de ces
sports lacerte
outre le côté possibilités techniques
je pense qu'il faut il faut justement
mallet et couvrir le maximum de
territoires avec ces nouvelles ces
nouvelles épreuves et le les yvelines
pour l'instant avec la confirmation ou
pas des dossiers donc des dossiers en
balance dont on parlait est suffisamment
bien lotis pour pour pouvoir bien faire
ce qu'elle à ce qu'elle a candidaté pour
accueillir et payet pas pour le reste
donc faisons les choses qu'on doit faire
bien voilà c'est ça si je comprends bien
exactement
vasile je pense que le sait le
skateboard se feront certainement au
centre de paris
je pense que ces sont des sports qui
justifie qu'on puisse lui fit avec lui
en toile de fond des monuments
historiques rendant le cachet omnium
donc je les avais dans le château de
versailles
on achète versailles mais on a déjà
l'équitation et le pentathlon au château
de versailles va n'en a pas parlé comme
communauté c'est je crois que justement
il en faut il en faut pour tout le monde
pour chaque chèque ville chaque mot
chaque monument de notre patrimoine
français le surf ça va être plus
compliqué l'imaginer dans les yvelines
et d'1 80 m
même si voilà il ya un projet dans le 93
à sevran d'une pole sur la côte basque
également mais à priori diaries la red
sea localisé il serait quand même plus
aujourd'hui comment penseurs fois là on
pense à
à biarritz à hossegor à lacanau et c'est
justement les villes qu'on dépose et ont
déposé un dossier donc cherished et en
plus à un moyen pour l'escaladent par
exemple pour le pour le vtt on n'aurait
pas pensé que ça pourrait s'organiser
sur la colline d'elancourt mais plutôt
dans les alpes et finalement c'est
organisé sur la colline d'elancourt
paris et les cultures la culture vélo à
dans les yvelines le surf le surf sur la
côte sur la côte basque j'ai enfin gea à
200% il faut que ce soit fait là-bas
pour la simple et bonne raison c'est que
ben comme je disais tout à l'heure on
sera au mois d'août et donc tu auras des
gens qui seront en vacances justement
ils pourront profiter des deux dd 2 d2
enfin les deux faire les vacances et
pouvoir voir des épreuves olympiques
vous partez en vacances là bas ça force
à du tout pas du tout paris voit 2024
paris jeu se fait à mes vacances sont
amarrés pas de souci et ensuite
pareil la voile la voile faut que ce
soit soit sur yon marseille ou deauville
ça aurait été top parce que deauville
c'est n'ont pas oublié 21ème
arrondissement
on y est très rapidement et je pense que
ça aurait pu avoir ça aurait pu avoir
lieu là bas
bon voila ce sera ce sera à marseille
très bien parce que les gens seront en
vacances là-bas il y aura deux épreuves
olympiques mais il faut qu'ils aussi de
la planche à voile faut voilà et c'est
vrai que pour moi je trouve que c'est
mal de pouvoir aussi utiliser un peu
tout le territoire et la richesse de
notre territoire pour pouvoir le faire
je regrette même que le canoë kayak et
lieu dans l'enceinte 17
j'aurais aussi préféré que ce soit
sur la montagne mais le problème qu'on a
c'est qu'au mois d'août souvent on n'a
pas assez d'eau pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir faire du jardinage qui pourrait
être qu'ils pourraient se sont organisés
un peu partout et le sait pas du tout où
on en parle pas du le fait d'être
olympiques alors le breakdance en tout
cas un passé à saint quentin en yvelines
avec la compagnie black blanc beur qui a
été l'une des pionnières du breakdance
de la danse hip hop en france sur plus
de quatre générations il ya des tensions
sur quatre générations
hélène parce qu'ils n'y aurait pas
intérêt à le faire ici à saint quentin
en yvelines
il ya un passé oui certes mais moi je
pense que c'est ces urbains etc en ville
je rejoins ce que disait c'est basile
qui disait ça pour moi ça doit être
enfin c'est en ville cette pratique
dehors un spot très bien pour le
breakdance et le parvis du trocadéro ou
alors pyramide du louvre yatuu pareil
devant la midouze ya des gars y'a de
quoi faire de saint quentin en yvelines
mais non des gens non pas par un autre
homme
oui mais voilà il ya plein de choses à
faire avec les cadors n'ont par contre
dans les yvelines
ils les skate board c'est pareil je veux
dire c'est ça demande une rampe sa
quille en skateboard via la rente après
il ya le il ya le street donc sa demande
que des petits modules mais ça c'est
pareil sur place il ya plein d'espoir
nadu ça pourra être fait la milieu de
l'arc de triomphe je suis désolé de
skateboard
c'est génial ya peu surélevé même dans
l'idée qu'on se fait de ce sport là pour
moi il faut que ce soit urbain il faut
que ce soit d'youville
voilà que ce soit graphie conseiller au
bureau nous taisons culturellement axé
ses accès ce n'est pas encore la fin de
cette émission encore une minute ans en
accession urbain il faut que ça soit il
faut que ce soit dans un trip jiri pehe
chef
le réalisateur veut déjà terminée il
veut partir en vacances
dernière question c'est la fin de cette
émission que ce qu'on peut souhaiter aux
téléspectateurs télé 78 et ses vacances
du soleil
des espoirs avec mes buvait frère cela
équivaut les sports un programme
physique suivies à la lettre par tiko
jeux olympiques peut-être du repos
[Musique]
partie base il réalise également des
stages pendant pendant l'été
éventuellement s'ils voulaient souffrir
contactez moi un petit programme six
jours sur sept
[Rires]
alors j'entends cet été c'est une
semaine de vacances parce que le reste
ces préparations championnat du monde
voilà vous ne verrez pas il ya du
jarrier sur les plages mesdames des
objectifs rendez vous à la rentrée alors
on va terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui nous sommes obligés
de citer pierre de coubertin fondateur
des jeux modernes chaque difficulté
rencontrée doit être l'occasion d'un
nouveau progrès je vous laisse méditer
sur cette phrase je vous souhaite
d'excellentes vacances sur tv 78 à
bientôt
[Musique]
comment se trouve que